if you had to boil down your drag race
experience and to just a few words how
would you sum it up
magical phenomenal unique beautiful
humble I wish I could say coordinated
ladies I've made my decision
Raja O'Hara Shante you stay
[Music]
scarlet envy trust me when I say this
ain't your last dance now sashay away
the world wants me and the feeling is
mutual
[Music]
season is all said and done what do you
hope The fans walk away thinking about
you oh my goodness well um I you know I
hope that people can can see this but I
can laugh at myself I think we all
should be able to if you take yourself
too seriously I mean it everything gets
a little blurry you know so just laugh
at yourself you know those girls would
make fun of you but though you know you
love you still did you make any friends
for life out of this group oh absolutely
absolutely you know I have to say team
New York we've gotten really close
I always knew them I we've never really
worked together that often and this has
brought us together so close we've done
all these amazing photo shoots
none of them you've seen yet but maybe
at this point you will have seen them
yeah the girls you know you can always
reach out to any of the girls on the
cast but the ones that are you share a
city with you know you can actually see
more often maybe the definitely shag and
honey you Nina of course they're all
wonderful girls they really are and
that's what's so interesting about it is
that sharing that experience with these
girls people that you might not be
friends with or ever get to know
suddenly you share this like very
intimate and very personal
possibly traumatic hopefully not
experience that you know and so you're
linked for life so it's it's almost
impossible to answer that question with
one
because you know gone through hell in
heaven and back girls you know
[Music]